uh one one of the things that ends up
being uh really interesting is if we go
back to 2018 uh and we look bitcoin had
peaked in 2017 at twenty thousand
dollars it had drawn down and it was
sitting somewhere around six thousand
dollars or so five thousand dollars so
it's drawn down like 75 percent and i
think a lot of people were like oh
it's down 75 percent like this is the
bottom quote unquote and uh and they're
getting very excited
obviously it puked all the way down and
eventually hit i think it was like 3 200
give or take uh and it was uh very much
a puke right there was kind of this
grind down to 75 percent drawdown and
then
and you hit that 3200 uh and then pretty
much from there once you hit the bottom
grind it up and and everyone knows kind
of what happened from there
is your expectation from a market
standpoint that uh these types of
markets will just grind down eventually
hit some bottom and then recover or do
you think that there is kind of that
puking or that final capitulation that
occurs uh that could uh send prices down
you know i don't know maybe a couple
thousand dollars in one kind of rabid
move or like how do you think about just
the expectation you would have for uh
what will eventually be the bottom
whether it's now or you know some lower
price
yeah
what's
for a bunch of different reasons the
setup here is not comparable to november
2018 it's just it's just not the same
for a bunch of different reasons
it's a much bigger asset class it's a
much more institutionalized asset class
that was a almost entirely retail driven
market
and you had this hangover
from 2017
that was
much more
uh excessive than the price action that
we had in in 2021 in 2020 and 2021 um
especially in bitcoin i would say
and so
i i i struggle to compare the two i
struggle to compare
the 6k level that we bounced off of in
2018 a bunch of times before we broke in
november and got cut in half i i don't
think that's comparable to like say this
29k level from july 2021 that's not to
say that i don't think we can lose 29k
this time around
because if the stress gets bad enough in
traditional which there's quite a decent
chance that it could we could lose that
29k level um
but
the
and it could like i said it could get
pretty pukey um
but the
i think the ability and the willingness
for the market
to look through uh
the short-term volatility and that
short-term pukiness
to to look at this asset class broadly
in bitcoin specifically and say this
stuff is all much higher a few years
from now
just makes now incomparable to
uh
to like that 2018 time frame when like
you know people just thought all this
stuff could go away after that after
that uh november 2018 price crash and
one of the things that i i remind people
of a lot because in this monthly market
update that we've been looking at charts
in
i i had these monthly highlights like a
bullet point of like
my subjective view on
the most impactful sort of news
announcements over the course of of the
month
and one of the things that i track
pretty closely that's just been
astonishing is the amount of
venture capital coming into the space
and the magnitude the breadth and depth
of the capital raises for projects
and then
the amount of of vc fund raises so like
the funds themselves and then
the projects that they've been funding
and you put that together and just like
the aggregate amount of capital
permanent capital that's permanent
capital that's coming into this space
uh is stunning and completely different
and you're talking about hundreds of
projects that have that already have
years of runway
today
and then vcs with billions and billions
of dry powder that they're sitting on
today if not another dollar is raised
into crypto vc
and all of that is going to be
deployed
over the course of this year and next
year and the year after that if not
another dollar permanent capital comes
into the space and it is that capital
that will
uh fund the
projects and the innovation that will
drive
additional adoption
that will you know put a bottom in for
this market and cause all of this to
head higher than it ever has been before
and like i'm about as highly convicted
on that as i can be on anything yeah i
tend to think that uh everything
involved with the fear of the market is
very very short term uh we could be
talking weeks right i don't think that
uh this continues for six months and
then we get a bottom or anything like
that like it feels uh maybe we're not
quite there yet but definitely there's
way more fear than uh
than usual and so that usually tends to
be a pretty good
indicator